Vsauce! Kevin here.
You may know May 10th, 2020 as Children’s Day
in the Maldives or Mother’s Day in Mexico. Or
Bono’s 60th birthday, or the anniversary
of serial killer John Wayne Gacy’s death.
But on May 10th, 2020, Australia had a
very serious question -- as a nation,
it collectively needed to know
how many sides a circle has.
The answer is... a little more nuanced than
it may seem. There’s the easy math answer,
the real life answer, and the answer
that’s part hard math and part real life.
Listen, the answer can be pretty straightforward.
If you’re LAZY, or if you want to stick to the
most basic math. A polygon is a two-dimensional
shape on a plane that has a defined number of
sides -- or actually, angles. It’s right
in the name, the Greek “poluganon” means
“many-angled.” Triangle is a trigon, three
angles. Tridecagon, 13 angles. And 13 sides.
But how many angles does a circle have? Well…
none, really. Is that a… none-agon? Naught-agon?
Zilch-agon? There aren’t any points at which
two lines make a vertex. That can make it a
monogon, which Euclidean geometry categorizes as a
degenerate polygon because its endpoints overlap.
But if you’re just looking at a circle, you aren’t
seeing any angles -- you’re really just seeing one
continuous side. There’s the first answer, a
circle has one side. The end? Right? WRONG!
WHAT IS A SIDE? This is where it gets tricky.
In math, a side is really an edge or a face
depending on whether we’re working in 2
or 3 dimensions. But in real life, a side is… a
side. You refer to the left side of your body or
the side of a ship, or the outside and inside of
your house. “Side” in Olde English pretty much
set the tone for how we think of the word:
it meant the left or right flank of a person.
But when we think about what a side
is, it’s always relative to the whole.
Humans have bilateral symmetry, so the left
of your body is a mirror image of the right,
for the most part. That whole unit -- your body --
means we can break it down into relative sides and
have it make sense. A side is about position
relative to something greater. Like, a side dish
of your meal is relative to the main dish of the
meal. The steak or whatever. Spaghetti? Hot Dogs?
You know what I mean! You can’t have the port
side of a ship without drawing a mental line
of symmetry lengthwise in its center. You
can’t talk about how the inside of your thigh
hurts without silently differentiating
it from the obvious outside of your leg.
Or let’s talk about starfish!
Look at a starfish because that’s
radial symmetry coming from the center outward.
It’s got 10 faces with two on each arm,
but we’d say it has five sides -- and each of
those sides has a left side and a right side. So
it’s got 5 sides or 10 sides depending
on how we’re breaking it down.
It’s positional. It’s
directional. It’s relative. But...
we’re supposed to be talking about
circles! Circles! Okay, Alright, alright.
Well, now we’ve got at least one
more answer -- a circle’s got
an inside and an outside, 2
totally legitimate sides. But
that’s probably wrong. Because...
WHAT ABOUT WHEELS? WHEELS.
You’ve got a circle and it’s rolling on a
flat surface. Between gravity and friction,
eventually it stops. Let’s imagine a wheel
as a perfect circle. Because it’s a perfect
circle and the surface is perfectly flat, the
actual point of contact between the two is
infinitesimal in size. Does that make the point
of contact a side? Probably -- and how many are
there? I could roll a circle 10,000 times
and it’s never gonna stop in exactly the
same place. That suggests there
are infinite sides -- just like
the coast of the continent that feverishly
wished for an answer to this very question.
The coast of Australia is infinitely
long. Don’t believe me? You should!
Imagine measuring the coastline of Australia
using a measuring stick 20 kilometers long.
Then you go back and measure it with a 1 kilometer
measuring stick -- the measurement would actually
be significantly longer because you’re able to
capture more detail in the twists and turns of the
coastline. If you did it by the meter? Even more.
Centimeter, Millimeter, nanometer, femtometer… the
smaller your unit of measurement,
the more you reduce the uncertainty
and increase that coastline. And if
your unit of measurement can become
infinitely small, then how does the
coastline NOT become infinitely large?!
It’s the same exact concept with ‘sides’
of a circle. We’ve got an infinite number
of points at which a circle can come
to rest as it’s rolling on a plane,
and the only limitation we have is
in our ability to measure it. So
how many sides would it have if we could count
the atoms, or the electrons, or the quarks?
Sorry, Australia, but how many
sides does a circle have just
doesn’t have a definitive answer -- depending on
how you look at the problem, a circle can have
no sides, one side, two sides, or… infinite sides.
So what side are YOU on? How many
sides do you think a circle has?
Let me know down BELOW in the
bottom side of this video.
And as always -- thanks for watching.